- [Narrator] For the
first time in 50 years,
Campbell's iconic soup can
looked different in 2021.
Even though the changes are
subtle, it makes the can feel.
- Like one that feels at home
in your pantry versus one
that you remember seeing
in grandma's or granddad's pantry.
- M'm, m'm, good!
(playful music)
- So let's break down
Campbell's first major rebrand
in decades and how those small changes
are breathing new life into soup,
the company's core product.
The redesign is so slight
that customers might not
have even noticed it.
- It was really important to hear
that Campbell's did this
evolutionary change,
didn't step away from
their iconic look and feel.
- This is Rob Meyerson,
the founder of brand
strategy firm Heirloom.
He's been studying Campbell's redesign
for a new edition of the book
"Designing Brand Identity."
Though Campbell's Soup Company
makes more than just soup,
its namesake product has been
on shelves for 130 years.
The label has been tweaked
many times since then
but only significantly
redesigned a handful of times,
like in 1898 when the company
first chose the colors
that would define it.
- The red and white on
the can, which is inspired
by the Cornell football team's uniforms.
- [Narrator] That red
and white wasn't touched
in the new redesign
but other elements were tweaked.
For example, the new logo gets rid
of the drop shadow and
disconnects the letters.
- Drop shadows are a little bit
of a relic of an era in design
where adding dimension
was seen as a positive.
Removing any unnecessary components,
like that subtle drop shadow
just puts all the more focus
on the recognizable assets.
- [Narrator] The overall
effect is a simpler,
more modern take on the logo.
And modernizing is a theme
throughout the redesign.
- The medallion, they
retained all of the text
and basically the same
imagery within the medallion
but they added some dimension to it
that looks a little bit more 3D.
It pops a little bit more, it
feels brighter on the cans.
The word soup has been
written in a different color.
They've gone from a serif typeface,
which has these little feet
and pieces on the bottom
of the P, for example,
and they've gone to
what's called sans serif
without a serif,
and that's typically a
little bit more modern.
They also retained this slant
on the interior of the O
and so I think this is
just striking a balance
between modernizing, refreshing,
but keeping some recognizability
between the old can and the new can.
- [Narrator] The company
did add something new,
a picture of each soup's ingredients.
- They've wanted to emphasize
the food ingredients
in the can.
- [Narrator] Aaron Back is a
Wall Street Journal columnist
who covers all things Campbell's.
- This is about reaching
young people who care
about food quality,
who care about what
they're feeding their kids,
and saying, look, there's
real tomatoes in this.
- [Narrator] And there's another
benefit to those pictures.
- Instead of using a picture
of a bowl of soup or a spoon holding soup,
they've gone with just this
simple shot of the ingredients,
the piece of chicken and the noodles.
And that alone makes them stand out
from everybody else in the space.
- [Narrator] So why did the company go
through all this trouble
for a redesign so subtle?
- The last thing you wanna do is make it
so that people don't recognize
your cans or your products.
- [Narrator] And that Campbell's can
was already so recognizable
and had been for decades.
It was memorialized by Andy
Warhol and in catchy ads.
- [Announcer] Campbell's
Tomato Soup, m'm, m'm, good.
- For a long time,
Campbell's iconic status
translated into very strong sales.
Around the turn of this
century, that came to an end
and they started running into problems.
- [Narrator] Soup sales began
a steady decline for years.
- The overwhelming perception
among young consumers
is that Campbell's soups
were old-fashioned,
unhealthy, out of style, and unappealing.
- [Narrator] Changing that was part
of CEO Mark Clouse's new
strategy to prioritize soups
after years of expanding beyond it.
Some of that expansion worked.
Campbell's Snack division now accounts
for nearly half of the
company's sales, but fresh foods
like baby carrots and
salsa were less successful.
The company ultimately sold its entire
refrigerated food unit in 2019.
- The insight of the
new management was look,
the name of the company is
Campbell's Soup Company.
It's our most important product.
- [Narrator] So the company tried
to appeal to younger consumers
by refreshing both the
label and the recipes.
- They took out high fructose corn syrup
from the condensed soup line.
The cream of mushroom,
cream of chicken soups
now have more fresh cream in them.
- [Narrator] The company
also tried new marketing,
like sponsoring an episode of "Top Chef."
- Gonna do a Swiss chard gratin.
- [Narrator] Making an NFT
and partnering with the Madden NFL game.
And so far it's helped.
Soup sales have grown in recent years.
That's in part due
to the pandemic when more
people were cooking at home.
♪ And it's magic. ♪
- [Narrator] But those lockdown
customers stuck around.
- Campbell, you know, not
too long ago, was viewed
as one of the most troubled
of the major food brands.
But last year was one
of the top performers.
Its stock went up to 31%,
and that was in an overall
down year for the stock market.
- [Narrator] Still, the future of growth
for Campbell's isn't just
in soup, it's snacks.
The company designates
that division's role
as accelerated growth,
but it was important
for Campbell's to staunch
its core products bleeding.
- Once you clean up the product
and also make the label
look more appealing,
what you do is you kind of
give a permission structure.
That's something you can
maybe even be excited
about to have a can
of Campbell's tomato soup in your pantry.
(pensive music)